today on the matt well show a pansexual
teacher is fired in florida for
discussing sexuality with her kids was
the school justified of course it was
but we'll discuss anyway also joe biden
claims that the right to kill babies
comes from god dr oz is called out for
his pro-abortion views during the gop
primary debate in pennsylvania dave
chappelle is assaulted on stage during a
comedy show this is becoming a bit of a
trend nasa scientists sexually harass
e.t with unsolicited nudes and our daily
cancellation will deal with what might
be
the dumbest and most morally debased
argument in favor of abortion that we've
heard from the left since the supreme
court news broke talk about all that and
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
did you know that uh if you're currently
on a phone plan with one of the major
carriers you are helping these
left-leaning companies donate to
pro-choice causes and candidates common
question i get from my listeners all the
time is you know what can i do to help
turn the tides in the culture war here's
a great first step defund the
abortionists don't let them take your
money and use it to further policies you
don't believe in switch to charity
mobile today and they will send five
percent of your monthly plan price to
any pro-life pro-family charity of your
choice charity mobile offers the latest
5g phones with no device or service
contracts plus they have great
nationwide coverage i've never had a
problem with the coverage with charity
mobile phones if this sounds like a
hassle you know making the switch it
actually isn't charity mobile makes
switching from your current carrier
painless their live customer service is
exceptional they'll guide you through
the process you can keep your number and
even your phone in most cases or if you
want you can take advantage of my
special offer and get a free cell phone
with free activation all you got to do
is call
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com i mentioned offer
code walsh to redeem the free cell phone
offer that's charitymobile.com mention
offer code walls join the fight
for children by switching to charity
mobile today
now that the anti-groomer law has been
put into effect in florida we have of
course been warned that apocalyptic
results will follow gay teachers will be
fired and mass gay students will be
expelled gay people walking down the
street will be rounded up and deported
anybody who says the word gay will be
immediately vaporized by a drone from
the sky this is the dystopia that we
were promised and yet
nothing like it has actually occurred in
fact
the media's had to search quite
desperately to find any real-life horror
stories connected to the legislation
that they erroneously labeled the don't
say gay bill
and now they think that they finally
found it the headlines came pouring in
yesterday a teacher in florida has been
fired
for her sexuality they tell us except
there's quite a bit more to the story as
it turns out here's the headline from
the new york post
it says pansexual florida teacher canned
for discussing orientation with students
now according to the article it says a
florida teacher claims she was fired for
discussing her pansexual status with
middle school students whom she then
asked to draw pictures representing
their own sexual orientations cape coral
art instructor casey scott said that her
students were curious about her sexual
orientation and she explained to them
that she was pansexual during a lesson
in march um in march going to nbc2
a discussion happened in the class and
because of that now i'm fired scott told
the outlet now
just to make sure that we give pansexual
casey a fair shake in this whole thing i
want to play some of her interview with
nbc2 where she tells her sad sad story
and uh let's do that now
a discussion happened in class and
because of that
now i'm fired that discussion according
to trafalgar middle school teacher casey
scott centered on student sexuality a
lot of the kids came out to me like oh
well i'm non-binary and a couple kids
said oh well i'm bi one kid said they're
gay she claims students wondered about
her i'm pansexual
so
like i like
anyone despite
female male and married to a man she
says some students asked to create art
expressing their sexuality this one's a
trans flag she hung the pictures on her
classroom door they said that it would
be in the best interest if i just got
rid of them now she snapped these
pictures showing how she got rid of them
i went over to the recycling bin i
grabbed all of their flags and all the
kids were staring at me
and i crumbled their flags in front of
them she was sent home and then i got a
call from administration saying that
well at this time we are releasing you
from your contract she showed us social
media posts from students upset over her
firing however the lee county school
district showed us complaints from
parents and students explaining that
they could create flags expressing who
they are union president kevin daly says
they can legally fire her during that
probationary period
they can let you go without cause she
doesn't belong to the union daley
believes the firing could be a wake-up
call for teachers there is kind of a
heightened sense of you know where is
the boundary
yes where is
the boundary
well um i can answer that
the boundary is simply this don't talk
to the kids
about your sexuality or theirs
it's got nothing to do with your job
it's not appropriate
it's none of your business it's not what
you're being paid to do
um i also don't want my kids dentist
talking to them about
their sexuality if the barber cutting my
son's hair is a pansexual and uh brings
that up in in the course of of of
cutting my son's hair i'm gonna have a
problem with that
in fact i don't want any adult talking
to my kids about sexuality so this is
quite simple actually it's
finding the boundary is it's not hard to
do and it's really not confusing
it's not difficult to understand or
abide by i've gone
if you can believe this
i've gone my entire life without ever
walking up to somebody else's child and
initiating or participating in a
conversation about sexuality
um i plan to keep that streak alive for
the entire rest of my life it's not
difficult normal people have no problem
with this
the fact that public school teachers are
scratching their heads you know and
going i don't understand it's so
confusing
i'm perplexed
really shows you what's wrong with with
public schools wait so when can i talk
to kids about sex
never
you never can
it's not your business it's not your job
get that through your thick skulls and
leave the kids alone again nobody else
on earth
it has a problem with this
you people are the only ones who are
confused about it everybody else we live
our entire lives and it's never a
problem
we we intuitively understand that it's
that it is far beyond inappropriate to
have conversations like this with other
people's kids
there is no temptation to have those
conversations there's never
there's no confusion there's no like
searching where's the line where's the
boundary
the boundary could not be more obvious
it's in bright neon flashing colors okay
that's how obvious the boundary is
so let's let's uh take this specific
case into consideration
and it's good because it actually does
demonstrate exactly how the florida bill
will work in action even though this
teacher's firing wasn't really connected
to the florida bill and in fact the bill
only covers kids up to third grade
anyway still we have a pretty good
example of the kind of thing the bill is
trying to prevent so
what happened here according to
pansexual casey who says she's pansexual
because she likes males and females
which actually makes her bisexual uh the
term pansexual is redundant and
meaningless but i mean never mind that
for now
casey says the kids were talking about
their own sexuality and then they asked
about hers
the correct response from a competent
adult in this situation is to say
this topic is not appropriate for the
classroom
and then change the subject the end
simple
instead casey tells the children all
about the wonders of her made-up
pansexuality identity and invites the
kids to create their own pride flags
which she then hangs up in the classroom
did she deserve to be fired for that yes
without question at best and i mean
the absolute best most generous generous
interpretation here is that this woman
is emotionally stunted immature
ill-equipped and was swept into this
inappropriate classroom conversation
because she lacks the competence and
basic leadership skills to offer the
kind of guidance and set the sort of
example that her job requires um that's
cause enough to fire her but again
that's like the most generous
interpretation
because in reality there's a reason
these kids felt comfortable talking
about this in her classroom in the first
place and even actively you know drawing
her into the discussion it's pretty
clear that she's initiated these types
of discussions in the past she may well
have initiated this one too and is now
lying about it
whatever your theory of the case
there is no plausible theory that
vindicates her
and there's other one other thing i want
to bring up
about this
so let's go back to the clip when uh
pansexual casey says the students wanted
to um you know draw the pride flags as
an art project
and apparently they didn't all want that
considering both parents and students
complained after the fact so there were
at least some kids in that classroom who
felt uncomfortable but many of them did
allegedly you know want to draw the
flags until the teacher was forced to
pull them all down crumple them and
throw them away in front of the class
now it does sound like she made the
whole thing more dramatic and theatrical
than it needed to be like i don't think
she needs to go right in front of the
class and tear down the pride flags that
they just put up and crumple them in
front of them um
it's
kind of funny to me actually but
whether she had to do it that way or not
let's go to
um minute 139 in the clip where we see
all the pride flags crumpled in a heap
now you can see that there now first of
all notice
just how many pride flags there are from
just one middle school art class
i don't know how many kids are in the
class but it couldn't have been more
than 20 or 30 at a maximum probably
fewer than that so
in this one middle school class of a
couple dozen students at most
that's how many identify as lgbt that's
how many
pride flags there were and you heard her
say it too well some of them were
non-binary they were trans they were gay
they were bisexual
in a middle school class
and note the actual flags we see there
in the pile
talking about these issues so much i've
unfortunately become very well
acquainted with these flags i'm
something of a pride flag translator now
and i can tell you that
we see there are multiple
non-binary flags so these are middle
school kids a group of them in just one
class
who have declared that they're that they
are neither male nor female
and then perhaps even more alarmingly we
see that you can see that purple white
and black flag which is i believe
the asexual flag
so there are middle schoolers young kids
who have decided already that they are
asexual
they've adopted that identity and are
literally waving the flag for it
so if you're wondering why the
anti-groomer laws are needed this is why
the social contagion has turned into a
full-blown pandemic
entire generations are being consumed by
it
children these days are so desperate to
be in the lgbt club that they're
assuming sexual identities that they
don't understand and that don't really
make any sense
that's how successful the lgbt
indoctrinators have been
and that's why we have to and are
fighting back
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
just like the foundation of our country
is uh the constitution legally the
foundation of your family should be your
faith and your beliefs so i have a
serious question for you something you
got to consider if something should
happen to you or your spouse god forbid
who do you trust to instill those same
core beliefs and values in your children
do you think it's the same person the
state would assign them to if you don't
have a will in place you have no say in
the future of your children that's just
the reality so let that sink in and
think about that for a second and if
you're single and you don't think you
need a will you couldn't be more wrong a
will allows you to establish advanced
directive and medical power of attorney
do you really want to leave the burden
of deciding life support or not to your
family members or close friends of
course you don't want that it will
allows you to clearly communicate to
your loved ones what your wishes are
regarding your health if you haven't
made one yet you're not alone but we're
going to make it easy for you at
epicwill.com when you use promo code
walsh we are so excited that they're
partnering with us in the daily wire
they're protecting our staff and their
families let them protect yours to
epicwheel.com promo code walsh this is
how easy it is you can secure your
future in as little as five minutes with
a complete will package starting at 119
and when you use promo code walsh you'll
save 10
epic will.com this will be the most
important five minutes you spend today
epic will.com
uh going immediately to the big topic of
the week and of the
century really um
roe v wade and its impending demise so
we're getting more reaction from the
left i want to play first we'll play
this clip um it's it's
consistent with a theme that we've seen
from the left of uh you know very
unfortunate and tragic transphobia that
has come to the surface
uh over the last few days and so here is
gavin newsom this is the most i think
probably the most blatant example we've
seen yet gavin newsom
who um
well you just have to you have to hear
it to believe it you have to hear this
transphobia and prepare yourself for it
uh i don't even know maybe this youtube
maybe this whole show will be taken off
of youtube because of the transphobia
that you're about to hear but here it is
consistently opposing all of those
supports hell they don't even believe in
climate science
talk to me about being pro-life
spare me
your body your choice
it's a hell of a moment to live in
but like you say we will not be defeated
we will stand tall we will stand firm
and we will affirm the constitutional
currently constitutionally protected
rights of women and girls their
reproductive rights and freedoms in
california
and we will assert ourselves as i said
as californians by punching above our
weight working with other like-minded
leaders and governors
and legislators all across this country
and we're not going to roll over we will
not back down
and we continue to fill in the gaps
and address the disparities that
continue to persist even in a state like
ours even in california
so you hear them there say that this is
for women and girls it's the rights of
women and girls so he's taking pregnant
men out of the conversations that's
that's bad enough but he tweeted out
that clip and in the tweet if you can
believe this he says
if men could get pregnant
if
men could get pregnant
this wouldn't even be a conversation
that's what he said in his tweets
introducing this clip of him
if
if
men could get pregnant
gavin
but they certainly can
right
and nobody will ever that's that's the
the great advantage of course the great
advantage if you're on the left if
you're a democrat and you have the
almost almost the entire media in your
pocket is that nobody is ever going to
call you on that no one is ever going to
follow up and say well what about i
thought that men could get pregnant
what's going on here
and that's all that's the only follow-up
you would need and it would be totally
utterly embarrassing for gavin newsom
because he would have to right then and
there on the spot
um abandon his whole you know feminist
talking point for abortion and but he's
never gonna be required to do that so
they're allowed to com compartmentalize
these issues
and put them into different boxes
where there's no there's no crossover at
all
like the boxes don't touch there's
everything they say about sex and gender
that goes here
and then there's everything they say
about abortion that goes here and these
are these are separated by there's a
there's a vast canyon separating the two
and they're never required to actually
try to harmonize these two positions
because they can't be harmonized
um on a positive end though the
republican senate primary debate in
pennsylvania happened yesterday and this
was um
an important moment from
one of the candidates who is
you know talking about her own pro-life
convictions and her own experiences and
also calling out dr oz who's on the
stage and i think right now still
considered the favorite to actually win
the primary and be the um the candidate
for the the gop for the senate in in
pennsylvania but he gets called out here
and i think it's a pretty great moment
let's listen to that
i am the byproduct of a rape my mother
was 11 years old when i was conceived my
father was 21. i was not just a lump of
cells as you can see i'm still not just
a lump of cells my life has value and
that is one of the reasons why it was so
very disturbing when i saw mehmet oz
running for this particular race when
i've seen him on numerous occasions and
specifically at the breakfast club
saying that my life was nothing more
than a uh acorn with electrical currents
i am wondering if the good doctor has
now since changed his position on that
my life is valuable and so are this and
so are the many lives that find
themselves in the womb of their mother
whether in the womb or towards the end
of that life dr oz you have 30 seconds
to respond that was directed at you sir
you know one of the toughest
endorsements you can ever get is from
your mother-in-law and my mother-in-law
is an ordained minister she wrote a lot
of the pro-life literature in montgomery
county where we live and she certainly
understands that i'm pro-life as a heart
surgeon i've operated on small children
few days old and witnessed the majesty
of their hearts pounding blood even
though it's ill because i'm operating on
them
through those bodies i would never think
of harming that child or even nine
months earlier because life starts at
conception
what
i i'm sorry i i hadn't even heard i
hadn't heard the clip with
i i i guess i hadn't listened all the
way to dr oz's response
and you know which is my mistake he's
got to hear him out what does he have to
say
um and apparently that's what he has to
his response
his response actually was my
mother-in-law says i'm pro-life oh yeah
well my mother-in-law
what
and he had to know he obviously knew
this was going to come up and so they
workshopped this thing and he had his
advisors and uh he obviously had this
this mother-in-law line and they said
that's a good one yeah throw that one in
there
that's that that's it that ends the
discussion right there your
mother-in-law says you're pro-life
and then he pledges that he would never
harm a child well
okay that's good i mean no one was no
one was accusing you of actually
physically yourself harming a child
although by supporting
uh
abortion
not to mention the chemical castration
and sterilization of kids you had you
have in effect harmed lots of kids
but that was a train wreck it was like
20 seconds from dr oz a total train
wreck
if you live in pennsylvania this cannot
be your guy this just this can't be him
um he's he's
playing the part he's playing the
character right now of a conservative
but the unfortunate reality for dr oz is
that he's been on tv
for decades and so all you have to do we
have tons of tape all you gotta do is go
to the tape and you can hear what he
said about all these issues abortion
he's been pro-abortion transgenderism
he's in favor of of medically
transitioning kids
you know gun control he's a big gun
control proponent
i mean how could you even consider if
you're a conservative
nominating him
it's total madness
now the woman there on the stage her
name is uh kathy barnett and
you know she
makes a really important point
and uh presents a challenge
for the pro-abortion side which includes
dr oz whatever he happens to be saying
right now
he's he is still on the pro-abortion
side
historically and uh whatever conversion
he experienced you know this late in
life
always be skeptical
time a politician claims to have
undergone some sort of
conversion where they've changed their
mind i mean people can change their
minds yeah
but if you have somebody who's a dr oz
is in his 60s now i think
so they've lived their whole life and
they're they're on the record over and
over and over again having a certain
position and then the moment they run
for office
that's when they have their road to
damascus moment and they see the light
a little skeptical of that
um
so
she presents a challenge to the
pro-abortion side and she goes right
after
you know with the the
the kind of the hard cases which is the
the
supposed to be the kind of unanswerable
argument from the pro-abortion side
which is well what about
rape what about rape and incest life of
the mother these kinds of things
even though it's all red herring it's
all a misnomer
because as we've said that's
less than one percent of abortions
and
um
even though on the left all they want to
do is talk about when it comes to
abortion all they want to do is talk
about cases of rape
they're neglecting the 99
and as far as their position on abortion
goes the rape is irrelevant
i mean they think no matter how a woman
happened to get pregnant
99 of the time it's they got pregnant
because they willfully participated in a
certain in the reproductive act and as
far as the left's concerned no matter
how you got pregnant you have the
natural god-given right to kill your
babies
um
but talking about the rape
uh
talk about cases of rape for just a
second so what you're saying is if you
think that abortion should be legal in
cases of rape
then what you're saying is that
kathy barnett should should not exist
like why should let's just personalize
it for a second
because these are actual human beings
we're talking about
babies that are conceived in rape these
are actual people and there are a lot of
people walking around today who are
conceived in rape
and you're saying that it should have
been okay to execute them to kill them
because of the sins of the father
how does that make any sense how does
that make logical sense
how is that morally or ethically sound
why should this is what you should have
to explain
if you take this position
whether you're full on pro-abortion or
you you know are
kind of pro-life but you make exceptions
and if you may if you're pro-life with
exceptions and you're not really
pro-life
but you need to explain why kathy
barnett
should have had to pay the price
for what her father did
pay the price with her life
make a moral argument in favor of that
because i don't think you can
all right let's uh move to this biden
speaking out yesterday had some thoughts
on uh
the extremism of the republican party
that he's very concerned about let's
listen to that
well that got struck down griswold was
thought to be a bad decision by bork and
i'm my guess is the guys on the supreme
court now
what happens if you have a state change
the law saying that that that children
who are lgbtq campaign classrooms with
other children
is that is that legit under the way the
decision is written
what are the next things that are going
to be attacked
because this mega crowd is really the
most extreme political organization
that's existed in american history
so now we've already heard that because
if roe v wade is overturned then as we
heard from eric swalwell yesterday that
means that uh next thing you know
they're going to abolish interracial
marriage
because you know those those
conservatives on the supreme court they
they're on the record opposed to
interracial marriage
they're so opposed to it that one of
them clarence thomas is in an
interracial marriage he wants to abolish
his own interracial marriage apparently
so we've heard that uh of course we've
heard that uh next they're gonna they're
going to overturn
gay marriage and now
biden says
that the next step is uh is segregation
in the classroom along sexual identity
lines
which of course is completely inventing
that in his confused
head
but also that that also happens to be
like again exactly the opposite
of the conservative position
when it comes to
sexuality and the classroom
no we don't want to segregate kids based
on that we we don't want to do anything
with it
we just it it's that's not what the
classroom is about
that whole subject we want to take the
whole not the people we want to take the
whole subject of sexuality uh
sexual orientation gender identity all
that stuff take that out of the
classroom because it doesn't belong
there
leave the people it's the subject that
we have a problem with
so this is uh this is gop extremism
or that mega crowd they're the most
extremist
political movement to come along
no it's it's not the people who believe
that we should be able to kill babies in
the womb up until birth up until 40
weeks they're not the most extreme
chemically castrating sterilizing kids
that's not the most extreme
speaking of an extreme
mega terrorist there's a guy named miles
taylor who agrees about the violent
extremism on the right and he says that
in fact he fears for his very life
because of it listen to this
if i had quit the bush administration
where i started my career i worked in
dick cheney's office if i had quit and
said bush and cheney were bad which i
didn't believe but if i'd quit in
protest they would have quarreled with
me
instead defecting from the republican
party and fighting maga they don't just
want to quarrel with me they want to
kill me
okay because i'm going out there and
saying the republican party my party has
been corrupted they want to kill me and
that's not hyperbole we receive death
threats but it's not just the me's out
there that went into this clear-eyed
it's poll workers it's school board
chairman it's just your neighbors that
are suffering under the politics of
physical intimidation
by merely trying to stand up on these
issues that is what is so alarming
they want to kill me he says who is that
guy again
i think we have to know i think you're
safe because in order to kill you
first of all we have to know who the
hell you are and uh
i don't think any of us do i just know
his name because it was on the
you know it was it was on the clip but
that's that's all i don't know who this
guy is they're coming after me to kill
me nobody knows who you are or cares
buddy
he says it's not hyperbole i agree it's
not hyperbole that they're coming after
him to kill him uh it's not hyperbole it
is just uh what we call bald-faced lie
that's all that is
all these people constantly i'm so tired
of hearing about oh they're setting me
to death threats
just so you know um
99.999 percent of the time when someone
talks about death threats they're just
lying
you know and then and then in the the
small number of cases where there are
death threats well that's
it's not good it's bad it shouldn't
happen
but
lots of us deal with it i do as well
but i can pretty much guarantee you no
one's coming after that guy trying to
kill him they don't even know who he is
especially not when you're he's he's his
claim is that the whoever this guy is
his claim is that
the
conservatives want to kill him
because he is arguing that the gop is
corrupt
every conservative says that we all say
that we all believe that that's that's
that is probably the one thing that
every conservative can agree on is that
the gop is corrupt
and um it's like the lesser of two evils
that's the position
i have never met a conservative who's
like super into the republican party and
loves it and thinks that it's perfect
i just love the republican party that
they're
they are guiltless and faultless before
god i've never heard
any conservatives say that
so yeah conservatives are hunting him
down to kill him for saying the same
thing that we all say
now i want to go back to that biden clip
because right before he went into the
mega terrorism and violence and
extremism um he made a claim that you
might say itself is rather extreme he
says
that abortion rights like where do they
come from
if we have the right to abortion the
right to kill our kids
where do we get that right where does it
derive from
and that's an important question rarely
does anyone on the left even try to
answer it biden
does answer but i think in his answer we
see why usually they avoid this question
would prefer not to talk about it but uh
here's what he says
what was the second one oh
look the second one was on abortion
as i said when i uh um
when this hit as i was getting on the
plane to go down to alabama
um
this is about a lot more than abortion i
haven't i hadn't read the whole opinion
at that time
but this reminds me of the debate with
robert bork
bork believed the only reason you had
any inherent rights was because the
government gave them to you if you go
back and look at the opening comments of
the work biden when i was questioning
him as chairman
i said i believe i have the rights that
i have not because the government gave
them to me which you believe
but because i'm just a child of god i
exist
i delegate it by joining this union here
to delegate some obligation rights i
have to the governments for
for social good
so the idea that somehow
there is a inherent right
that there is no right of privacy that
there is no right remember the debate we
you don't remember but we had a debate
about
uh griswold versus connecticut there'd
been a law saying a married couple
could not purchase birth control in the
privacy of their own bedroom and use it
okay so the right to abortion comes from
god he says
and so he is introducing god
into the equation
he's doing that and remember what i said
yesterday
that while the left complains
about pro-lifers allegedly you know
throwing the the bible at them and and
uh yes they say get your religion out of
my uterus and all this kind of stuff
they accuse us of being the ones who
make this into a religious topic they
are the ones 99 percent of the time i
keep giving i've given the 99 statistic
for a lot of different things today on
the show but um here's another one
that's
i'm making up but my guarantee is is
probably true 99 of the time
when you hear somebody
someone on the left
you know if you hear that
religion is being discussed in the
context of the abortion
issue it's someone on the left
introduced it even while they complain
about it so remember that from biden and
then meanwhile you've got this tweet
from kirsten powers who's a usa today
columnist she says if you think abortion
is wrong don't get an abortion it's not
okay to impose your religious view on
others why should a jew or muslim have
to live according to your interpretation
of the bible if you don't get this
please don't ever use the phrase
religious freedom again
so
um never mind the fact that religious
jews and religious muslims also don't
believe in abortion either but but uh
she says
okay well you're the one bringing
religion to it but here's the present
united states
a democrat
saying that we have the right to
abortion because it comes from god
and when you introduce that
well now of course we're going to engage
with it because you brought it up
now i actually we don't actually need
recourse
to the bible we don't need recourse to
uh christian doctrine in order to
explain why you shouldn't kill babies
okay we can make that argument without
recourse to any kind of
um
religious claim
but if you're going to bring it up then
yeah we're going to engage with it
because we can't allow you to just go
around claiming that god wants you to
kill babies
or that somehow it's consistent with the
bible or scripture
to murder your own offspring
so
biden's claim that god gives us the
right to abortion
okay
he says god gives us the right to
abortion because it gives us the right
to privacy
but already this doesn't make any sense
at all
god gives us the right to privacy if you
believe in god then you believe first of
all that there's no such thing as
complete privacy because everything you
do and think
is known and seen by god
so already that's out the window
and what does abortion have to do with
privacy
first of all it's not something that
you're just doing on your own
and even if it was
god doesn't let you off the hook for
that
as long as it doesn't involve anybody
else i mean you can we we learn
especially in the gospels you can sin
within your own heart
in the way that you think about about
people and you can sin that way lust
hatred that's that is a sin
and that's as private as it gets
but with abortion there's another person
involved
so privacy has nothing to do with it
and also even if you did have a right to
privacy that god himself recognized well
like god's turning away and saying oh
you do what you want
hey this is up to you man i'm i'm
staying out of this one
um
even if that is how it worked which it
isn't
how could you have the right to privacy
or the right to anything
if you don't first have the right to
life if you don't have the right to live
in the first place then how can you have
the right to anything else the right to
life has to be the first most basic
right if you don't have that right then
what are all the other rights built upon
and the right to life is is itself built
upon the idea that human beings have
intrinsic value and worth and dignity
and because we have that intrinsic value
worth dignity that's where our that that
is the sort of the wellspring from which
our um
our human rights arise
but if you believe in abortion
then you believe that we have no
intrinsic worth value or dignity
because at our very earliest stages when
we first come into being in that moment
and for many moments thereafter uh you
are expendable you can be
killed and tossed into a dumpster
and it's no it's it's not a moral
outrage at all it's not a crime
so if you reject the idea of intrinsic
value and worth
then you have nothing you have no hook
onto which that you can hang your your
theory of human rights
so the whole thing is totally incoherent
all right let's go to this from the
daily wires as an attacker who rushed
the stage and tackled dave chappelle on
tuesday the comedian's hollywood bowl
show was carrying a knife concealed in a
replica gun according to a new report
a 23 year old man was arrested as being
held on 30 000 bail and the um la county
sheriff's custody on a felony charge of
assault with a deadly weapon
and so this guy
i think we still don't know why he did
it exactly we can maybe theorize about
it but dave chappelle was at this big
comedy show and he was
on stage and somebody rushed on the
stage
and then he was
you know dave chappelle's personal
security putting the academy award
security to shame because they took this
guy dragged him out and just beat the
living hell out of him and there's a
there's an image of him that you could
see where he's being carted away the
attacker was anyway and his arm is
twisted like a pretzel okay it's twisted
in a direction that it's simply not
supposed to go
um which which honestly like that's what
should happen
if you rush the stage and attack
somebody in the middle of a performance
that's also how you dissuade other
people from trying the same thing
so when i see this story there's two
things that come to mind first of all
i'm trying to figure out the strategy
of hiding a
knife inside the replica of a more
dangerous weapon
that's what i don't get
oh nobody's gonna suspect i have a a
knife oh how's that how then no one gets
because i'm gonna hide it in this gun
that's how no one's gonna
the security will never know i have a
knife because they'll just think i have
a gun instead
it's like it's like if you had a weed
and you you hid it in a box labeled
heroin it just doesn't make a lot of
sense
and um
perhaps more importantly though and we
still we don't know the motivations or
anything else but
it stands to reason
[Music]
that this could be a this is a further
consequence of the you know words are
violence
mentality
which has especially been applied to
dave chappelle
now we can't say for sure that this guy
was motivated because he thinks that
dave chappelle is a transphobe or
something but certainly the message in
society has been that jokes and words
are violence
and when will smith attack chris rock
lots of people on the left especially
came to his defense and said that hey
making that joke about
a woman with alopecia is a form of
violence
when you when you tell people this
um and especially if you're saying it to
someone who is already prone to being
delusional and half crazy
and you tell them that words and jokes
can actually cause them physical harm or
worse than physical harm well then you
are
encouraging exactly the kind of thing
that we just saw
all right before we get to the comment
section uh
let me see if i can find this there was
another story that was really important
okay so
you know we used to worry about
scientists covering up
aliens you know the existence of aliens
but now i think we have to worry about a
different kind of sort of uncovering the
new york post reports this week
nasa to launch naked pictures of humans
to space in hope of attracting aliens
now
i want to make contact with aliens as
much as the next guy
apparently not quite as much
but we need to seriously think about
about the sort of contact
that we want to actually have with these
creatures
and i mean look at our attempts to reach
out to aliens have been so far as far as
we know unsuccessful
if this is what finally earns a response
i'm not sure that's a good sign
if they were ignoring us up until now
and then we send we send naked pictures
out and now they respond
i i just i don't what's the strategy
this is another area where i'm confused
about the strategy now for hoping to
avoid a visitation that i could maybe
understand sending out pictures of uh i
don't know you know lizzo or something
for example that would surely dissuade
any intelligent race from landing here
but avoidance is apparently not the plan
this is from the new york post it says
nasa scientists plan to launch pictures
of naked humans into space in the hope
of luring aliens to us
the depictions will also include an
invitation to respond
should an intelligent alien race find
them
the pictures aren't graphic photographs
of naked humans but a drawing of a naked
man and a woman next to a depiction of
dna the man and woman are waving in an
attempt to look more inviting
nasa scientists revealed the image in a
study that's part of a project called
the beacon in the galaxy
the main aim of the bi tg project is to
send a message to any alien
civilizations that could be out there
oh so that's our excuse for stalking e.t
with unsolicited nudes
and if he's offended we're just going to
say what hey
sorry man we just wanted to show you our
our beacon
and here's my question
what if e.t
sends nudes back
are we really prepared to see that
i am certainly not
and like i said what if he does more
than return the favor what if this is
really
the thing that draws them here
what if as the poet once said uh the
milkshake really does bring
the boys to the yard what then
the perverts or nasa are going to get us
all turned into sex slaves
here's think about this way 50 years ago
and i'll stop talking about this in a
second
50 years ago scientists were landing
humans on the moon
and now because apparently only fans is
running the space program we are
flashing an entire alien civilization
from 90 million light years away
and it actually gets worse because and i
haven't looked this up but i'm pretty
sure about this
um this this uh this uh uh deep space
probe shall we call it that we're
sending out this is actually not the
first of its kind because i'm pretty
sure that there was a probe in the 70s i
think was the pies either the voyager of
the pioneer thing was the pioneer
where we also sent naked pictures
and that craft is now wandering through
space
50 billion miles away totally ignored
so we slid into the aliens dms with
naked pictures
they ignored us and now we're so
desperate that we're sending another one
it's like the anthony weiner strategy of
galactic diplomacy i guess
um
which is why i suggest a compromise
really which is that um
rather than sending the naked pictures
let's just send
the aliens pictures of
uranus instead
so
that was the worst joke of the bunch i
had to do it though i mean i just can't
like i'm a dad it's you've got the
uranus joke laying right there you've
got to make it and so that's it
you know one of the most shameful things
in this country is uh the the countless
cases of veterans coming home from
overseas and not being supported not
being cared for in this country and
that's something we have to fix and
that's why i'm so excited to talk about
a company that is really making a
difference for our nation's veterans one
more wave one more wave uses surf
therapy to help veterans stay active
engaged and connected the founder of one
more wave alex west is a retired navy
seal who noticed that for many veterans
especially those with adaptive needs
standard off-the-shelf surfboards and
equipment were off the table so what did
he do he created a team of surfboard and
artists and serve instructors to work
with grant recipients to design the
custom equipment for their experience
level and physical needs from there one
more wave connects veterans to their
global network of surfing volunteers who
empower them to heal through surf
therapy from coast to coast fresh salt
air sunshine and the exhilaration of
flying down the face of a wave help keep
veterans coming back more and more since
2015 one more wave has empowered over
500 veterans to find healing and
community through surf therapy by
providing customized surfing equipment
and community but to keep on going we
need your support help fund 10 new surf
therapy grants by going to
1mwave.com
dailywire sign up to become a monthly
sustaining donor as well there the
average veteran grant costs 2 500 and
every tax deductible donation counts
help us continue to support those brave
men and women who have given so much for
this nation visit
1mwave.com dailywire and become a
sustaining member today one more wave is
a 501c3 and your donation is tax
deductible visit 1mwave.com for more
information
let's get now to the comment section
all right let's see what we got if i can
find it we are uh
idankpo augustine says people who can't
define what a woman is because they
aren't biologists suddenly turn to
experts at defining the beginning and
viability of a life
well not really actually they that's the
interesting thing is that they don't
claim
to have an answer to when life begins
you know it's it's not as though they're
saying
oh life doesn't begin at conception it
begins
somewhere else
they avoid the question entirely and if
you try to get them to answer it they're
going to say that well i don't really
know it's above my that was obama's
famous answer i think was it's above my
pay grade
and so
that's another bit of incoherence from
the pro-abortion left that they admit
that they don't actually know when life
begins
and which means if they don't know then
if according to them it's possible at
least that life begins at conception and
so but they're not sure
but we're going to go ahead and
slaughter the babies anyway
knowing that at least they might be
human lives
so you actually you give them a little
bit more credit than they deserve with
your observation there chris says isn't
it kind of strange that so many of these
leftists you feature on your show are
unemployed and miserable they're all so
full of themselves they should be
successful because confidence
is the key to success
well but self-absorption is not
confidence so that's the first problem
the the two things are not the same not
even really related
um
and uh in fact they're in conflict with
one with one another so what you see
from the
leftists and everything and it's it's
self-absorption and narcissism but not
confidence
which is why they're also they're
self-absorbed narcissistic but they're
also deeply in need of affirmation from
the public
um and also the other thing by the way
is that i don't think it's true that
confidence is key to success
i think um
one of the keys to success anyway is not
confidence but conviction
which again is not exactly the same
thing
you have to believe in what you're doing
you have to have a
cause that you believe in that's
conviction so that is a prerequisite for
success
and along with conviction you also need
humility i think if you really want to
be successful
because humility
is how you improve
uh it's how that's that's the striving
that's the improving
so conviction and humility
is what you need all right rachel says
not gonna lie the thought of matt
singing the fruit salad song to his kids
just made my day however if we
tragically lose the wiggles to the left
perhaps matt michael andrew and ben
could wear different colored plaid
shirts start a conservative children's
parody band
and save the day
i think we are going to lose the wiggles
and you know i wish that i could gloat
about it because like i said i i've
the wiggles have been a bane they've
been
the bane of my existence ever since i
became a parent
and um
and so
and now my my wife is
and it's mostly her fault that this has
happened because she has indoctrinated
each
successive child into the wiggles cult
and so i can never escape it
and now she's very upset with the
wiggles because she's you know
some this is not the first thing there's
been a little there's there have been
hints of wokeness i think from the
wiggles and i wish i could gloat about
it but it's actually just sad to have
yet another
formerly innocent if terribly annoying
uh child's entertainment property that
goes woke it's quite a sad thing
um
and let's see this is a great comment i
wanted to read from two shows ago and it
says dear god i can't even remotely
imagine decimating my family completely
destroying my child's life all to pursue
fleeting shallow lust for some dude i
met at a hotel bar this is the most
narcissistic and frankly evil thing i
can imagine a mother or father for that
matter doing and she got exactly what
she deserved when he rejected her and he
was right in doing so he probably knew
that if she'd destroy her whole family
after hanging out with him for a couple
hours she could just as easily turn
around and do the same to him over as
much or less with some new guy this just
blows my mind honestly my absolute worst
nightmare is for my marriage to fall
apart slash fail it's one of the worst
things i can imagine other than
something bad happening to my child the
idea of my precious daughter growing up
without her daddy in the house flawed as
he is lol is just horrifying to me um
yeah it's i i feel exactly the same way
when you hear all these stories of and
that's it's always stories from not
always women but often women who are
publishing these stories of tearing
their marriages apart and it's not
because
women are the only ones who tear their
marriages and families apart men do it
too
but women are the only ones who can get
away with bragging about it after the
fact and writing books about it and
articles and everything and being
published in cosmo or whatever um and
and being celebrated by a certain
segment of
the culture
with men that's never going to happen
but every time i read these stories and
they're going out of their way to dress
it all up and make it seem like it was a
wonderful bold courageous decision and
they're so happy now but you know that
it's that that's
a put on that that's rationalization
once again they're looking for
affirmation they're trying to convince
they're trying to convince themselves
by convincing us that they're happy
and in reality you look at this you just
think it's
i know sometimes marriages fall on hard
times you go through rocky patches but
it's just never worth it
you are
whatever you're going through in your
marriage it is it is worth fighting
through it
because the alternative
is the absolute devastation of your life
and your family
and that cannot be a better option
you know when the culture begins to
reflect everything but our values it's
time that we build our own build our own
culture so we are the daily wire is
taking on hollywood razor companies that
cave to the woke the publishing industry
and uh none other than the entertainment
staple of our childhoods disney we're
doing all that stop giving money to
organizations that don't respect you or
your values help us build alternatives
where the left is tearing down
foundations we are building and we need
your help today so head to dailywire.com
subscribe use code walsh for 20 off your
new membership and join us in our fight
to preserve real american values today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know all the leftist talking points
in response to roe v wades and pending
demise have been incredibly weak but for
daily cancellation i want to focus on
what just may be the weakest and dumbest
of them all well maybe not the absolute
weakest and dumbest when you you know
delve into pro-abortion arguments things
get so dumb so quickly that it could be
hard to parse one from another it's kind
of like splitting the atom at a certain
point for example a guy named alex
falcone
who i think is an actor or something put
out a lengthy tweet thread yesterday
where he compares abortions to
miscarriages he says this
this is a change of tone for me on here
but i don't think anybody actually
believes fetuses are people i think
they're lying there are almost a million
miscarriages every year in america it
happens to almost everybody but we're
not constantly getting invited to
funerals nobody who says abortion is
murder is out carrying signs that say
and miscarriages are suicide
right alex because babies don't miscarry
themselves intentionally
that's why we don't compare them to
suicide you stammering idiots
miscarriages by definition happen
accidentally unintentionally tragically
so there's nothing to protest that's why
we don't have rallies against
miscarriages you know we also don't have
rallies protesting the existence of
cancer
you raise money to try to cure cancer
but no one no one is out protesting it
does that mean we reject the personhood
of cancer victims no
of course not
and as for grieving miscarriages go talk
to any woman who has suffered a
miscarriage and ask her
if she considers the miscarried child to
be a person or not
alex is trying to delegitimize the grief
over miscarriages in order to justify
murdering children that's the sort of
person we're dealing with
also if fetuses are not people then what
are they alex
you'll notice again the the pro-abortion
person never wants to answer this
question they can't answer it
they say that the fetus isn't a person
and even that is
so self-evidently isn't a person that
nobody could possibly believe otherwise
he says like it's self-evident that it's
not a person
but then they never ever actually
explain what category the unborn child
belongs to
fetus is a stage of development it's not
a different species any more than
toddler or teenager or
senior citizen
is a different species
these are all labels we place on
different phases of a human beings a
person's
physical development saying it's a fetus
not a person it's like saying
alex falcone is
middle-aged not a person
but this is uh not the stupid argument i
wanted to focus on in this segment
instead
i'd like to call our attention to
um a different sort of argument this is
uh
one as evidenced by leela cohan who's
another hollywood leftist she tweeted
this
if it was about babies we'd have
excellent and free universal maternal
care you wouldn't be charged a cent to
give birth no matter how complicated
your delivery was if it was about babies
we'd have months and months of parental
leave for everyone
that's a talking point we get this a lot
now katie porter is a democrat
congresswoman she made a similar point
on msnbc yesterday uh listen
this is a terrible setback for all
americans it's an assault on our freedom
including our economic freedom
what does it mean to live in a country
that's trying to compete worldwide and
we're the only country that doesn't have
a universal paid leave that doesn't have
affordable child care
and now that doesn't have reproductive
freedom this is a terrible outcome not
just for women but for all americans
this is a fundamental assault on freedom
and what i feel mostly tonight is anger
and a deep sense of sadness that my
daughter betsy and my sons luke and paul
are going to live in a world with less
freedom than i did my mother or my
grandmother that is a terrible setback
for this country
she's getting emotional
at the idea
that um
her children may not be able to kill her
grandchildren
she's emotional about it
we'll address that in a moment but i
also think we need to play what's
probably the most colorful example of
this sort of argument as it was
articulated by anna kasparian of the
young turks uh listen to this
we don't even have paid family leave
we don't even have affordable child care
in this freaking country
okay and the people who fight against
those kinds of laws are republicans
and yet what do you want them to do with
their kids when they have to go to work
what do you want them to do what do you
want them to do i want them to answer
that freaking question answer the
question journalists ask them the
question ask them ask them
uh yes ask them the question please do i
mean ask me the question i'm happy to
answer it
what do i want parents to do if they
can't afford child care well let's first
talk about what i don't want them to do
i don't want them to kill their kids
killing your child anna is not an
acceptable child care option
the implication of kasparian's argument
and katie porter and all the other
leftists raising this point about
unaffordable child care and a lack of
paid family leave and so on is that we
should kill kids because caring for them
can be
expensive
now if you're pro-life and you also
believe that there should be more
government programs in place to help
families that's fine i have no problem
with that point of view
okay in fact um i think there's
something to be said for the only
hang-up is that before we start adding
more entitlements we need to massively
reform really dismantle and rebuild the
entitlement system as it currently
stands right now we're dumping hundreds
of billions of dollars every year into a
system that's essentially made to be
abused and manipulated and which hasn't
helped anything hasn't helped
has not helped uh
address really the the poverty problem
it's only made it worse
because we're taking single able-bodied
young adults and putting them on the
dole and keeping them there rather than
requiring them to work and exert
themselves and make the necessary
sacrifices to be contributing members of
society if we can separate the wheat
from the chaff and get rid of the dead
weight and restructure our entitlement
program so that they specifically are
designed to help families who are
struggling
i'm more than open to that
and that is a perfectly reasonable
argument for any pro-life person to make
and many of them do
but if you're pro-abortion then you
don't believe that life has any
intrinsic value anyway and if you're
arguing that abortion is necessary is a
cost-saving measure then we have a word
for that it's called eugenics
your position is not just wrong but
morally abominable
the leftist argument as we just heard
it's this
we don't have affordable child care or
enough entitlement programs for families
in this country and so let's continue
killing children in order to cut down on
costs oh also we should actually keep
killing children regardless of the child
care situation because a mother has a
sacred right to execute her own
offspring
i mean you could hardly claim the moral
high ground
while you put a gun to a child's head
and say give me my entitlements or i
blow his brains out
because that's exactly what the left is
doing here
and again even if they get the
entitlements they'll still kill the
child
it's a it's a it's one of the reasons
why why you don't negotiate with
terrorists
because whatever they're threatening to
do they're still going to do it even
after you give them what they want
so it's a monstrous argument and it's
also a red herring the truth is that we
could have free child care free diapers
free formula free food free housing free
everything for everyone and they still
would support abortion with all of the
same passion that they support it right
now
here's a question someone asked anna
casparian if we had all the stuff that
you say you want
would you be in favor of abolishing
abortion
or even limiting it the answer from you
is no so what are you even talking about
this for it's irrelevant to your
argument and you know it
there's one other point to be raised
here
the left while pretending to defend the
agency of women has actually removed
agency from the conversation entirely
anna asks you know what are women
supposed to do if they can't afford to
have kids she answers her own question
by saying that they should simply kill
their kids and have their bodies tossed
into a medical waste dumpster and uh you
know and that's her solution
she doesn't even consider or pay lip
service to the other potential solution
for women who don't want to or feel they
cannot care for children which is this
don't have them
and when i say don't have them i mean
don't conceive them if you conceive a
child you've already had a child it's
too late to not have a child once the
child is conceived so if you really
cannot handle a child
don't want a child don't feel you're in
a position to be a good parent whatever
the case
then what about the option
of exercising self-control
see the defenders of autonomy
don't recognize this option at all
because they want women to be helpless
slaves to their own you know compulsions
and passions they don't actually want
women or men to take charge of their
lives and make responsible decisions
they prefer that you make bad decisions
and then try to erase those bad
decisions with even worse decisions
if they have you in a self-destructive
you know victim spiral
then they have you exactly where they
want you
that's what it comes down to
and that's why the pro aborts are
certainly not for the first time and
certainly not for the last
today canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22. the young turks anna kasparian gets
to the heart of the liberal freakout
over abortion the supreme court gives
christians a major free speech win and
joe biden's hhs secretary doubles down
on irreversibly mutilating kids check it
out on the michael knowles show